how to use the results in the new
personality test for progress in life
try to compensate some sites that that
received fewer points well at the risk
of sounding self-serving that's actually
why we developed the self authoring
suite was to help people improve their
let's say performance and mental health
now we don't have direct evidence that
will that will improve personality but I
suspect that that evidence would take a
very long time to accumulate what we do
know is that the self Arthur ensuite
especially the future Arthur ensuite
helps people helps University students
for example stay enrolled in the
university it increases the probability
of that by about 25 percent and
increases grade point average by about
the same and there's good theoretical
reasons for assuming that writing is a
good way of writing about yourself and
about your past and about your future is
a good way of catalyzing personality
transformation because it appears that
personality the human psyche is
organized at the highest level of
abstraction using something like self
narratives and a well-developed
narrative makes a frame for your life
and helps you stabilize your negative
emotions and also experience more
positive emotion because you only
experience positive emotion relationship
to a goal and that can make
goal-directed activity a lot more
rewarding so you know it's a lot easier
to engage in activities that aren't
intrinsically rewarding if they're
linked to something that you really find
important and so I would say if you want
to work on your personality well the
first thing you have to do is figure out
who it is that you want to be and then
you have to make a plan and maybe you
have to clean up your past as well and
the self authoring suite was designed
you know quite carefully in order to
help people do that with a relative
minimum of effort not that it's easy
because it's not but a relative minimum
minimum of effort compared to other
technologies let's say and like like
long term psychotherapy and to make it
cost-effective as well so